[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عام 2001
الاف بي اي في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
صنف مجموعه اسمها جبهه حمايه الارض او
جبهه الحفاظ على الارض بانها الخطر الامني
القومي الاكبر في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الاكبر بتلاقي مع كل ظاهره
الاكبر الاول كمان
[موسيقى]
بعدها الكلام صار بشكل كبير جدا على فكره
ان ازاي يقترن
نشطاء حمايه البيئه بالارهاب وصار بدل
كثير جدا جدا حوالين الموضوع وكان في رفض
في المجتمعات الاكاديميه والبحثيه وفي
صفوف الناشطين في شؤون البيئه ان احنا
نقرا المصطلح الارهاب بالبيئه ولكن مع
تصاعد الممارسات العنيفه الخاصه بالجماعات
البيئيه المتطرفه واتجاه البعض ان هو
يستغل قضايا البيئه ويوظفها السياسيه
لتحقيق اهداف سياسيه بالضغط على الحكومات
او الدول او الانظمه لفت النظر لاهميه
المصطلح ده مش بس كده هو لفت انظار
الحكومات نفسها ان هي تدرجه في القوانين
بتاعتها
[موسيقى]